here to discuss is florida governor ron
desantis governor
welcome to the show we appreciate you
joining us again
great to be with you dan as always thank
you sir governor you've led the way
on coronavirus sanity the entire time i
live down here
i am a constituent of you as a resident
of florida um
what do you plan on doing about these
new mass guidance edicts from the cdc
um is there any potential that we can
have these mandates
banned in florida i know you just had an
executive order but is there
a legislative solution in florida that's
due to ban the mandates not ban
masks but to ban mandates
well we've already done it i signed a
law in june
that terminates all the local
government's ability
to impose restrictions or mandates on
individuals or on businesses
so that is not happening in florida and
it certainly will not happen
by me or at the state level as well now
the one area
where we didn't necessarily legislate
was with the school districts
and so last school year some school
districts had mass policy
others didn't many of our private
schools had mask optional same with
charter schools
dan the results were no different um
there weren't that really major
outbreaks no matter what
and so this coming school year every
every district in florida had planned on
doing
optional for masks and i think that's
the right policy
the cdc comes in and says every single
person in a school
students teacher staff have to be masked
at all times
that is not consistent with the evidence
that is not data driven
and so you started to see one or two
school districts say hey we're going to
follow that and impose mass so i just
signed an executive order
which says under florida's parents bill
of rights
the parents should be the ones to decide
whether they want their kid to wear a
mask in school if you believe in that
that makes you feel
good and you want your kid no one's
stopping you but that should not be
imposed on everybody
and we got to give parents the choice
dan a lot of these kids
suffered under wearing these masks
there's a lot of harms that come with it
and i think that we're basically
empowering the parents to be able to
recognize
what's best for their kids and i think
in most instances what's best for the
kids
from the parents perspective is going to
be go to school mass-free
yeah i'm sorry kevin i should have been
specific about schools in that question
you're absolutely obviously accurate
about what you have done to combat these
destructive mandates
and you've seen governor even in blue
leaning counties in florida like broward
where they're looking at these mass
mandates again you're seeing governor a
grassroots effort and
by the way as you know very well
governor it's not just amongst
republicans
but amongst democrats parents too who
are saying listen i just want my kid
to have a normal school year governor
the mortality rate according to an op-ed
by dr marty mccary
for kids who don't have comorbidities or
diseases the mortality rate
from this virus is zero percent
yeah and i think dan one of the dangers
i feel with
having mandatory mask at this point
given the statistics you
cite i think a lot of those bureaucratic
authorities are going to say hey
we mask for covid flu is more dangerous
for kids than covid
maybe they need to mask the kids every
flu season and then it just never ends
and i think if the cdc had its way
i think they probably have kids in mask
indefinitely
and you're right dan this is not a
partisan issue parents have to deal with
this
in real time just like last summer there
was such a hysteria because florida was
going to go to school in person five
days a week
and the media was was raising a ruckus
and some of these other people but i'll
tell you parents across the board
they wanted the ability to send their
kids to school and i think it's the same
thing this year
with the mass they want to be able to
send their kid they want their kid to be
able to be normal
and the schools are really the perfect
place to do it because they're one of
the lowest
risk environments we have for covet and
the data on that is very clear
you know governor the you know the irony
here is that you know one of the reasons
you were elected originally was because
if you were you've been an open advocate
for school choice
and a lot of minority parents supported
you many of whom traditionally voted
democrat
i'm out i live in florida i don't get
how much but when i do get out people
come up to me they know i'm a republican
they tell me they say listen i'm a
democrat but i think you guys are right
on this i think a lot of them believe
this is a fear campaign
i mean when you look about at governor
they're not using hospital
hospitalizations and deaths they're
using cases
now listen it's good to know that but
candidly it's almost a meaningless
statistic if a lot of vaccinated people
are showing up as cases
but many of them are in fact
asymptomatic
exactly and i think that's the thing
like i think the vaccines were sold that
they'd prevent infections
um i don't think that that's happened i
think a lot of people have tested
positive who are in vaccination
who are vaccinated but i do think it has
helped particularly elderly people
guard against really severe outcomes
including death and so what you have is
you have cases you have a lot of people
who are vaccinated testing positive
but they have an incredibly mild illness
well why would we want to just shut down
society
because of that and i think nationwide
we are at one of the lowest points for
daily uh reported mortality
for the entire pandemic and i think that
that's a that's a reason why so
yes fear doesn't work i think people are
sick of that i think they see that
people have an agenda and they
constantly want to do it and dan you and
i both know
there are certain people who never want
the hysteria to end for their own
purposes and we can't let them win
florida's free we we pride ourselves on
people being free to choose how they
want to govern their affairs
governor desantis thank you very much as
a constituent and as a host of the show
thanks for everything you're doing
trying to keep florida
free we really appreciate it i know
you're busy thanks for the time
god bless you man thanks hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else